Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness. Grab your workbook.
Let's get started. Today's theme is about the sin
nature one more time, all right? And so it's a challenging one.
Here it is. This is day 12. We're going to talk about how the
twistedness inside disguises itself.
I imagine you remember probably playing hide and seek when you were a kid.
You remember that one place that you ever found to hide, that place that
nobody could see, nobody could ever find you right there, right?
The sinful nature is really good at hide and seek.
If you've ever seen someone do sleight of hand, right, that was really good at it,
they do the old cups and balls trick.
They say, "I'm going to take this one right here. We're going to take it.
We're going to take it like this, and we're going to take it and vanish it," and
then it appears back under the cup. Whoops.
And then it appears back under the cup, and you say, "Well, here's another one
right here. I know, let's get rid of that one.
Surely we can do this one." You take it.
I love doing it for kids because they're always so surprised when you take it and
you vanish it.
And then you take it and appears back under the cup, and you say, "Well, that's
it. I'm going to take it right here." And you reach out and you grab one in midair,
and you take it like this and say, "All right, let's take it and get rid..." And
there it is right there. And we're going to take it, drove it right through, down
into the... And we're going to take it like this right here.
And then when you think you've got them all, there's more, and they just keep
appearing. I know, that's just a silly illustration.
I like playing around with it. But here's the thing.
Sinful nature can feel very much
like someone is doing sleight of sin with you.
Now, let's get rid of all that. Let's go to the scripture.
Today my goal is to help you pull back the camouflage, see
behind it, and catch what's really going on.
Jeremiah 17:9 says this: "The heart is deceitful
above all things and beyond cure." Or King James will say,
"Desperately wicked." "Who can understand it?" Now,
I'm going to come back to that beyond cure later, and we'll talk about what God can
do to cure the incurable. All right?
But I want you to not miss that last phrase, "Who can understand it?"
The implication is that we can't even understand it.
The sinful nature is a master of disguise, and it
remains in the human heart after salvation.
Now, salvation is powerful, wonderful, and great.
New creation, old things pass away, all things are new.
It's amazing to be saved and a new creation.
What it means is that you completely start over. Your guilt is gone.
Your conscience is cleansed. It's as if everything in the world is
done and finished, and you're raised from death to life.
You're adopted into God's family. It's wonderful.
But every theological system from every denomination recognizes this is
the case. That the cowboy in me, the nature of sin remains.
Catholics believe it, Presbyterians believe it, Methodists, Baptists,
Pentecostals,
and more. They all believe that. Now, that's hard to get five different
denominations in a room and have them agree on anything,
right? But they all recognize this one as true.
We have actions of sin,
but behind them is the nature of sin itself, and that nature remains
in the heart after the actions of sin are forgiven and
we're regenerated in the new birth. It is bound, yes.
It is weakened, yes. It is not ruling, but the sin nature is
present. So what is the sin nature?
Well, it is a warping of the human spirit
caused by the absence
of the sanctifying presence of the Creator. Right?
Adam and Eve didn't have something added to them as
much as they lost something.
They were holy by the continual presence and connection they had with God, but
they lost that. They were created for God to be
turned toward him, and they lost that sanctifying presence, and
their nature bent in upon itself. It was designed to focus
on God and his glory, and it twisted inward to focus on
their own glory, their own way, their own self.
And this emptiness, this twisting, this bending towards
self is the essence of what sin is. Not
just actions, but nature. A bend toward self and
self-sovereignty. You say, "Darryl, are you just making this up?
Have other people noticed this too?"
Let me read you some lyrics from another popular song in the
world. Okay? John Mayer wrote a song called "Gravity." He said, "Gravity is working
against me. Gravity wants to bring me down.
I'll never know what makes this man, with all the love
that his heart can stand, dream of ways to throw it all
away. Gravity is working against me.
Gravity wants to bring me down. Twice as much ain't twice
as good, and can't sustain like one half could.
It's wanting more, it's going to bring me to my knees."
Wow.
There's a guy who knows.
There's a guy who's fought it. He's struggled with it.
He calls it gravity, but you know what it is that's pulling him down?
It's the sin nature. He's twisted in upon himself, and he can't figure out
why.
Isaiah said, "We have turned everyone into his own way."
That's gravity.
Now, don't miss this. The world would look at that and say, "Well, that's not
a bad thing. Go your way. Do your own thing.
The highest thing is to thine own self be true."
But this is the corruption that we have.
And Christians realize
that self-sovereignty is ultimately the cause
of everything that's wrong with us.
The heart of our problem is the problem of our heart.
So it's ridiculously good at disguising itself.
It can disguise itself as self-esteem.
It can disguise itself as self-protection.
In a million other forms
But in the final analysis, it's a corrupting influence that exists
behind things. It's a mixture of self in all things.
Self-rights, focusing on and fighting for my own rights.
Self-admiration,
thinking of myself more highly than I think of others.
How about self-interest? Taking greater interest in my own
things than the things of others.
How about self-pity? Feeling sorry for myself when things don't
go my way.
Self-righteousness,
feeling that I am better, I am more right, and
better morally than others. Self-indulgence,
giving to myself privileges and perks that I might
deny to others.
Self-preservation, protecting myself and my wants
and my needs at the cost of God's will or at the cost of others.
Self-sufficiency, believing, sometimes
subconsciously, that I can accomplish what is needed
regardless of God's help.
And how about self-will?
Wanting and choosing my own way,
rationalizing and excusing however I need to.
These things are quite at home in churches, aren't they?
A.W. Tozer, a writer, a brilliant quote, he said, "These may show themselves
in the grosser forms such as self-promotion or egotism, but
they are the underlying cause. They seem to almost
feed off orthodoxy of beliefs, and are as at home at
a Bible conference as they are in a tavern." Haven't you ever seen these Christians
that are right in all the
different ways, but it's like they're mad about it?
And they're still selfish, and they're still angry, and they're still hurtful to
other people.
A.W. Tozer said, "Remember,
Peter, who followed him, also rebuked him."
Right? Now, I think most of you
may have some pullback in you from calling these things
evidences of the sinful nature. And here's why.
Because the culture around us continually preaches to us that
they are good. Like protect yourself. Look out for number one.
Nobody else is going to do it. You're a snowflake. There's nobody else like you.
But here's my question. Do these things sound like Jesus?
Self-rights,
self-pity,
self-indulgence, self-preservation, self-sufficiency,
self-will?
No.
They don't.
And let me remind you, I don't care what the culture says, or
what your church teaches, or what your college professor says, or what your
brother-in-law once told you. I don't care.
I only want one thing for you in this 40 days.
I want as much of Jesus in you as God can get into you.
That's what I want for me. We're not after common or ordinary.
I don't want normal Christian life.
I want maximum Jesus, maximum holiness.
If you were to suck all the air out of this,
put that cap back on, and then roll it in the mud.
You'd have the emptiness of the lack on the inside, the
deprivation that Adam and Eve suffered, the loss of the
sanctifying presence of God that held them in shape.
That's where we are. That's the cowboy in me.
And the gravity that's pulling us down, like John Mayer talked about, that's the
sinful nature. Because when God's gone, it's a vacuum that twists us up,
literally bends us towards sin. John Wesley called
it our bent to sinning.
Richard Taylor,
the Nazarene writer said, and I'm paraphrasing here, he said, "The sin nature is
the leftover tendency to assume I'm in charge in
the everyday non-sinful decisions of life."
We're not just dirty, we also don't sit straight.
The songwriter said, "Prone to wander, Lord, I feel it.
Prone to leave the God I love." So what is God going to do about
all this? Can he even fix it? Can he restore this?
Can he clean up the outside and wash it off?
Can he fill the inside and straighten out what has been
bent?
Yes, he can. That's what we're going to start talking about next.
Now, thankfully, I have to tell you, this is about as dark as it gets. Okay?
I know this is a heavy topic. If you can push through this far and
bear to look into this mirror of the word of God and say, "Sinful
nature is difficult, and hard, and sneaky, and selfish."
If you can bear that, it's going to get brighter from here. All right?
We're going to talk about how God sanctifies even the deepest parts of our
sinful nature. Stick with me, because we're going to talk about how God
refills, and straightens out, and washes off all that has been
bent in our nature, all that has been bent within us.
He fixes that which sin has broken. All right?
So be encouraged.
Good days are ahead. Lots of joy ahead as we talk about what
God does to fix and repair that which is sinful.
God bless you. We'll see you tomorrow.